[Music]
do you guys use your laptops when when
you're on a plane yes yes use them you
know yes I try not too much too big I
know you use the little tray in front
yes I use all the time what about it
has anyone ever reclined well yeah it
happens sometimes it looks like it
crowds my space it just pushes the floor
I think you just hinges sport but then
if you recline - you could call I did
it's a little uncomfortable but you know
I make it work true well not for this
guy oh holy [ __ ] about the flight that's
a Delta flight snapping part Wow
well my laptop's small so it doesn't
really get in the way but it also looks
like he has his [ __ ] tucked up under the
recline that looks like a big laptop
does the one with the two speakers on
the side yeah I have that one too but
this one actually this is 15 oh yeah
you know what pisses me off is I'm fine
in Vegas and some lyric lines I'm like
it's 45 minutes i recline all the way to
Vegas your dick hey we paid for the seat
yeah I could do what I want you gonna
start pushing the back of my seat bro no
in passing I was gonna sit there judge
you soundly for 45 minutes you don't
read client your [ __ ] long I don't
know [ __ ] I don't know you I don't
really refine I have a client
immediately when I'm allowed to yeah I
think it's [ __ ] rude you know this
guy because he got soft
okay so here's the initial tweet he said
at Delta a small note for the suggestion
box maybe have a little warning sign or
some way to prevent my laptop from being
destroyed when the person in front of me
reclines their seats was the editing and
then yeah he was editing it looked like
editing yeah I thought it was the video
editing where it's a photo oh I thought
it was see-through I thought you could
see the pamphlets in the front of the I
thought I thought it got that rare
yeah yeah then he added at Delta also
this is this one is more of a critique
than a suggestion I really appreciate
that your flight attendant came over to
tell me that the press injure in front
of me needs to be able to recline and
then asked him if he was okay as if your
seat hadn't just ruined my livelihood
and then he went on to say at Delta a
silver medallion member here how many
sky miles is a brand new Mac Pro at
Delta let me know who I feel about this
you'll know it's me because at the
bottom of the email will read sent from
my iphone well he's a silver medallion
is it gold yeah he talked about it he
said that he was on his way to become oh
no gold is the next stage it's silver
gold and then it's platinum and then
it's something else diamond or some [ __ ]
didn't travel that much what did you
complain about yeah that's why he didn't
know yeah there's a there's a first
level and in their silver and Enders
gold I barely fly really oh but is it
being a delta platinum member kind of
just like you want in like a local
beauty contest it is it's it's not the
time Delta's not bad guys it's not bad
out of the three major are you sure
that's dead yeah I think Delta's so I
always enjoy my double there you gotta
compare it to United in American because
you can't compare two JetBlue's a
different American got better but
they're perfect you got snacks now and
they're professional I losing your
luggage I've lost like three times at
those times you really they got better
very recently because I just took we
just took American fights every [ __ ]
where and it was pretty tight yeah yeah
branding fired all the angry people's
cuz every American airline flight I've
been on I look out the window and I see
a Samoan guy body slamming on the
luggage truck into peak height in the
[ __ ] slamming and that happened to
take this [ __ ] stroller
and it's like the super heaviest
Maggie's treating it like it's a purse
if it's fragile he's all like every
single future grant Johnson that I see
is working for American Airlines by
citation I may get bored at work what do
you expect yeah Julie you work out I try
to do that work fast I don't think this
is the airline's fault though
I don't either because I use my laptop
all the time mercury retrograde I see
sure
yeah that too yeah cuz like I feel like
even when legal like I think you're
you're you can still set up your laptop
in a way of it if the person reclines it
doesn't get smooth I don't understand
people that fortunately this person
probably put it all the way the [ __ ]
back like that when the chair came back
it was like [ __ ] I think for sure I
don't think that the airline has any
responsibility here and that's that's I
think they were being nice too because
they ended up responding to his tweet
and they were like oh no can you send us
your info and like we'll DM for review
and they ended up giving him 7,500 bonus
miles was equivalent to about $75 oh and
so he was like at Delta is giving me the
equivalent of sunny fate he's kind of
entitled yes an esky member oh is this
yours like in an explanation I'm a
SkyMiles hamburger and they use it you
know he ends up saying all that but then
they were saying that this is what they
actually wrote in the email thank you
for writing for writing us about your
experience I'm sorry your laptop was
broken due to another passenger
reclining on your seat it's not fair
when one person's behavior affects
another seat another person please know
that personal property damage in flight
as a result of a passenger action is not
reimbursable and we regret the
inconvenience and the goodwill gesture
legal 77 this guy's an idiot because
it's an accident and it's just as a seat
reclining bag it has nothing to do with
the guys like that's reclining like he
doesn't know but that's not support that
I think the guy reclining as a courtesy
everyone should at least like take a
quick glance before we ladies nobody
on the window-seat though what if this
guy's are Russian how would you be able
to see huh what if he's a Russian
pedestrian and as the seat was coming
back here's my chance he stuffs his
laptop in there purpose
I see that I think professionally
written and handled by Delta because if
it was frontier they're like dear guy
we're so glad you laptop got [ __ ] up
on our flight anything spirit there like
it was spirit there like we should
charge you $50 for bringing a laptop
onto the plane how did you get food how
did you sneak it on the boil
we weighed you wait you well those seats
wouldn't even recline on the way this
allegiance reclining like you're like
hey can I apply my seat and they're like
sure they come with a credit card
machine and they swipe you have to pay
30 bucks and then you can recline it
yeah oh yeah I was tripping out because
when you recline it it's literally like
half an inch
well it's like this I couldn't even do
that Allegiant or spirit I actually
looked and there's like a like a bolt
that goes like this and it screwed to
the seat and screw to the chair so yes
you can so you can yeah I forgot what to
do some [ __ ] yeah
wrench feeded that guy punching the the
back of the seat though I didn't know
that there were there was a divide on
airplane etiquette about reclining I
didn't know even what do you mean hold
the device I told you we were reporting
it we got like a lot of people are
saying that well you should never
recline why you know there people are
like the [ __ ] I paid for that [ __ ] I'm
reclining so I don't like it but that
doesn't mean everyone should have to not
like it - um I will here's what I do I
don't look but I will recline slowly to
give the person almost like a little
warning if they're [ __ ] eating or on
their laptop to adjust a little bit he's
got a double tap at the end so I was
quite this and then just to make sure I
am at the know oh yeah that is what yeah
I recline although the car is like in
reversing you go
now I gotta make sure I'm at the end
yeah man I mean why can't you use all
the options that are given to you yeah
yeah I just don't personally hate it I
know because I'm big already
there's a [ __ ] no space for anything
at all and then somebody's coming in my
space my time my [ __ ] arms your
clothes I know but I just feel bad for
the person behind me because I
personally asked if you hate it I could
I could if I really cared to because the
first time I experienced that I didn't I
was all my flight to Australia a ozzie
guy he was like hey when I when we get
on the flight like I'm really tired can
i reclaim this back and I was like yeah
you don't even have to ask me and he was
super polite about it and I was like
damn I would never say no to somebody
look if they're like hey Caroline I
would everybody know I think maybe I
don't I don't um I'm not on your level
with it because I'm so tiny that I get
comfortable in any seat you know I'm
saying so it's like I've never been that
so here's some of your claims I'm not
like oh god I'm like I'm so good you
could recline - yeah you know what I do
ask though because whenever I always
make sure I have the window seat and
then I always like put it down and knock
the [ __ ] out but what I've been doing
recently is like I feel like maybe some
people like to look out the window and I
have my hood over my face anyway so I'm
I was like hey guys do you guys care of
this over not because I'm gonna knock
the [ __ ] out and then like so if they
want to look at the window I'll leave it
up and then I'll [ __ ] in do you ever
bring binoculars I used to always love
the window but now I'm always aisle
me too so I could go up and pee as many
times as I want without bothering
anybody or not never but like very
rarely so I love the window and you can
hold your pee for like eight hours I
couldn't like a 12-hour plan I could
just go pee one brilliant I drink I
[ __ ] on the water now cuz the flights
give me something hydrating yeah yeah me
I'd rather sleep there I'm sorry whoa
sorry guys there are two notes
I'd rather sleep so I just I just do the
you know usually people understand how
it works it's not a big use not really
fun to fly yeah you don't talk next
I don't you want to have conversations
never you don't either how you know that
I travel with you all the time
we talked like Oh from how many hours we
went to Florida oh yeah unless it's like
an eye I will do the headphones I'm not
gonna talk unless it's an old lady who I
for old man who I feel like they really
like having a conversation I'm like here
all right
what does it sound what is it what kind
of knowledge is this said shut up if
you're on spirit they put old lady's
next to you who wanna thought yeah yeah
and then they cool and then they charge
you for the conversation and then when
you looking at the window you see the
small guy taking your luggage and chuck
it into a wood chipper
we lost your luggage we lost their
[ __ ] deal with for a reason yeah but
if you pay if you pay extra like ten all
this money who's come out and they start
doing the haka for you and it's pretty
[Music]